- [Voiceover] Hello, grammar pals,
and welcome to the future,
full of jet packs and
spaceships and shiny jumpsuits,
and also the word "will"!
There's a lot of will in the future,
by which I mean we use this word, "will",
to form the future tense in English.
So, in the present tense you'd say,
"I eat this cupcake."
That's the present.
But in the future, you would say
"I will eat this cupcake."
Because we use the future
to talk about stuff that's
happening later than now.
Literally, it's in the
future, so it's later,
as opposed to the present,
which talks about now, and the past
which talks about stuff
that has already happened,
happened earlier.
So the most common way to form the future
is to just make a sentence
in the present tense
and then before the verb,
just stick "will" in there.
So, "I pet the triceratops."
Everyone's favorite dinosaur.
Wish I could pet one.
Can't, they're extinct.
"I pet the triceratops."
But in the future, maybe
when they clone dinosaurs,
"I will pet the triceratops."
And we will be best buds.
So that's the most basic
way of forming the future.
You can also use "is going to".
So you could say,
"Lorraine is going to visit Canada."
And that's another way to form the future.
But the most common way to do it
is to just put in "will".
Just write the sentence as you
would for the present tense,
but then you just gotta pop in "will".
"I eat this cupcake." is the present,
"I will eat this cupcake." In the future.
That's the future tense.
You will be able to learn anything.
David, out.